[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone
to first year transfer and eli whitney
students
welcome to yale i also extend a warm
welcome to
all the family members and friends who
join me in
recognizing this milestone in your lives
today we begin a new academic year
at a time of significant upheaval
historically social conflict and disease
pandemics
have catalyzed change and so
we should not be surprised that many are
calling now
for further transformation of our
society
we are dealing with two parallel crises
the covet 19 pandemic and
the racial inequality and injustice
rooted in our country's history of
slavery
and still facing us today
we have all been affected by these
challenges especially members of
the black and brown communities who bear
the brunt
of these burdens i've been giving
a lot of thought to the university's
role in addressing
difficult social issues much remains to
be answered in this turbulent period
but what is certain is that the core
mission of yale
is more relevant than ever
i am sure each of you has studied yale's
mission statement
yell is committed to improving the world
today
and for future generations through
outstanding research and scholarship
education preservation and practice
yale educates aspiring leaders worldwide
who serve all sectors of society
we carry out this mission through the
free exchange of ideas
in an ethical interdependent and diverse
community
of faculty staff students
and alumni research
scholarship education preservation and
practice
are vital to understanding our past
building on hard-earned progress
identifying what
still needs to be done and creating
change
you know this it is why
you are here
you will be studying with professors who
use their knowledge and expertise
to improve the world yale faculty
members work with government officials
and others
on containing the spread of infectious
diseases
mitigating health disparities
transforming policing
and reforming the criminal justice
system
while addressing challenges like these
you will learn
from your teachers how to analyze
problems
think critically and communicate clearly
along the way you will also be
encouraged
to focus on yourself
whether fighting a global pandemic or
the scourge of racism
global climate change or economic
recession
we must be willing to be honest about
our own motivations
and open to changing our minds
efforts to solve pressing problems will
not be effective
if they are led by individuals who
cannot feel
compassion nor learn to cooperate
nor by those who try to achieve change
through manipulation coercion
or brute force yale's faculty
understands this
i recently discussed compassion with
sterling professor of sociology
elijah anderson he has contributed
immensely to the study of racial
inequality
particularly in urban settings but he
also has put his expertise into practice
as a consultant to the white house and
to congress
i asked him how does he teach students
who want to improve the world
he told me that he shows his students
how to see the world
from the point of view of others how to
have empathy
such an ability he noted can help us to
be better scholars
and students to be more sensitive to the
human condition
and to be more self-aware when we are
motivated by empathy
compassion and cooperation
we can bridge differences learn to
understand
one another and enact meaningful
sustainable change
empathy and compassion a willingness to
engage those with whom we may not see
eye to eye and a concern for the
misfortunes of others
are preconditions for cooperation
cooperation working together to solve a
common problem especially one that we
cannot
overcome by working alone
requires us to listen to each other
charitably appreciate each other's
perspective
and inhibit our desire to dismiss
individuals with whom we
initially believe we cannot develop
common purpose
the enemies of compassion and
cooperation
are fear and anger
now i'm not saying that it is
inappropriate to experience the fear
caused by a pandemic of a novel virus
that can be fatal
and i'm not saying that one shouldn't
feel anger
indeed outrage at the killing of george
floyd
by former officers of the minneapolis
police department
in fact covent 19 makes me
anxious and those former officers
who took a sworn oath to protect the
public
they leave me livid
but although such fear and anger can be
motivating
i must ensure that they do not prevent
my finding common ground
with well-meaning others whose
approaches to social challenges
are not the same as mine
i must engage them rather than attempt
to silence them
to accomplish anything real and lasting
let me provide an example from politics
at one time women who became pregnant
and the men who wanted to take time off
from work to care for an infant
were at risk of being fired by their
employers
but in 1993 the u.s senate passed the
family and medical leave act
guaranteeing family members the ability
to take a prolonged unpaid leave
without risking their jobs in order to
tend to a
newborn adopt a child or assist
a sick family member how did this act
which was considered revolutionary at
the time pass
well it was developed cooperatively by
senator ted kennedy
among the most liberal of lawmakers and
senator orrin hatch
among the most conservative they opposed
one another on many policies
but in this case they found a common
cause
supporting families they both felt
compassion toward individuals at risk
for losing their jobs due to childbirth
and perhaps more important they
respected each other
as individuals listened to each other
and placed national interest ahead of
party differences
their cooperation led ultimately
to significant social change
one final thought about the importance
of compassion
and cooperation most of you
members of the class of 2024 are part of
generation
z the post-millennials
i am well a baby boomer
perhaps you have heard that you and i
are quite different true
you are the first digital natives and
the only world you have ever known
has included the smartphone texting and
social media
and you are distinctive in other ways as
well
yours is the most racially and
ethnically diverse generation
in american history and you also promise
to be the best educated
but it is not only that we are different
in these ways
we are also said to disagree we are told
we have different views on
politics music and work
i am sure you are familiar with the
stereotypes that
exaggerate our differences and
stereotyping is another barrier to
compassion and cooperation
for example you fought by generation for
the great problems of our time
and my generation too often fails to
understand you
we pass you on the sidewalk mystified by
your earbuds
and your clothes we tell you to grow up
to get off social media to develop
some real life coping skills and to get
out of your parents basements
and get a job and to us you say
okay boomer thanks to an article i read
in the wall street journal
a print edition of it in fact i am told
this is a sly linguistic weapon of
intergenerational warfare
well although such stereotypes give rise
to internet memes
and other kinds of click bait to get us
to think of our differences
as intergenerational warfare we
are not at war those are distractions
and they won't help us link arms in
overcoming
what might be standing in the way of our
future
our shared future
at the heart of ok boomer is the belief
that my generation contributed to the
serious
even existential problems in the world
that you will enter and lead
your generation sees the challenges
posed by climate change
abuse of policing war racism
and poverty you recognize the urgency
of these problems but my generation does
as well instead of dismissing
one another's perspectives and focusing
only on difference
we need to direct our attention to
creating something better
for all who will follow us
we can only do that by harnessing our
compassion
and cooperating here at yale
we learn from each other that is why
academics like me
enjoy spending their entire lives on
college campuses
and it is why you chose to come to yale
the passing of knowledge and the
responsibility to do some good with it
from one generation to the next
is a large part of yale's mission
it is hard work so please
use your time at yale wisely
let us devote ourselves to learning
together
to the personal transformation that the
pursuit of knowledge
can create for each of us
let us use these college years to change
ourselves
to become more compassionate human
beings
and then let us work cooperatively on
existing and emerging challenges to
create the world
we desire welcome
to yale